I would love to know in the comments
section what you would call your red
pill moment just like Elon Musk add over
the weekend what even is a red pill I
don't know it's a little bit of a
complicated question what would you say
your red pill moment is because Elon
Musk's just over the past few days he
tweeted out take the red pill and then
there's a little red rose emoji which
actually makes it a little bit confusing
exactly what he was saying what does the
red pill mean if you were to ask a
hundred people in a room he said what is
the red pill you might get a hundred
different answers if you asked
independent minded people you know not
conservative but not leftist maybe
they're they have some kind of confusing
views their left-wing on one thing right
way on another they would say that
taking the red pill is to think
independently if you ask a conservative
what does it mean to take the red pill
they'd say it's to become a conservative
to stop being a liberal or a leftist or
a progressive and if you were to ask a
left winger what is the red pill they
tell you it's a code word for Nazi and
they actually did when Ilan Muscat
weeded this out over the weekend
everybody just said Elon Musk is a Nazi
now he there was a blue checkmark Molly
John fast
who said Elan musk is a racist he's a
bigot it's anything you know that the
left has done this in recent years
they've said that a bunch of innocuous
symbols are code words for neo Nazis so
they did this to the okay hand symbol
they said that's actually now like a
secret Nazi symbol they did this to a
glass of milk that's now basically a
swastika and they're doing it to the red
pill which is a reference to the movie
The Matrix you know people are
forgetting that this red pill idea it's
not some dark recess of the internet you
know it's hidden on the hidden levels of
4chan it comes from the matrix and in
the matrix there is a choice presented
said you can take the red pill and you
can see reality as it is or you can take
the blue pill and you can remain in the
kind of matrix fantasies that I think is
the most basic definition
when you apply the red pill language to
politics it means giving up ideology
realizing that ideology is a lie I think
this is why Elon Musk put that little
red rose there because the red rose is
another Twitter symbol that refers
explicitly to the Democratic socialists
of America so you see a lot of very far
left-wing accounts at the little red
rose picture this is kind of odd races
take the red pill and then a little red
rose
was it because Elan musk doesn't know
what that red rose means is because he
thought it was a red pill instead of a
red rose was he being ironic or
sarcastic what is he well on the one
hand on the one level the one thing we
know ill on musk is really good at is
getting everybody to talk about him he's
one of the greatest marketers of his age
but on the other hand I think there's
actually some significance to it maybe
which is regardless of exactly where you
want to try to pinpoint me down on the
left or on the right er in the middle
take the red pill means rejecting these
ideological categorizations it means
most basically recognizing that the
official narrative is wrong it means
preferring reality to theory this is a
big difference between the right and the
left on the right the conservatives that
are best
we prefer reality we don't really care
about how it works in theory we don't
need it there to be a big manifesto
about how things work as long as it
actually works and on the left they
don't care if things actually work they
don't care if American society basically
works pretty well they don't care if the
West has led to a lot of human
flourishing they want to know how it
works in theory
Elon Musk is not a typical Republican
Joe Rogan he's another one of these he's
not a typical Republican right Joe Rogan
was a Bernie bro as of two months ago or
something but now Joe Rogan is saying I
can't vote for by time I end up voting
for Trump and now the left is very upset
with him for this he's resisting
ideological categorization but I think
there are a lot of people like Joe I
mean obviously there a lot of people
like Joe Rogan his show is one of the
biggest podcasts in the world I think
there are a lot of people like Elon Musk
who were a little bit more independent
minded
and who are coming over more to the
right if this were 20 years ago 15 years
ago this were during the Bush era you
might see more independent minded people
leaning left but now they're heading in
the direction of the Republicans or the
Conservatives or Trump why it's because
they're questioning their assumptions
they're taking the red pill they're
preferring reality to this kind of
official story that permeates our whole
political lives that we've been told
that probably isn't all that true and
the people most responsible for doling
out those red pills it's not me it's not
some other conservative it's not even
Donald Trump it's the media it's the
mainstream media
[Music]
you
[Music]